[Applause]
[Music]
talk with the king
yes September 28th baby you know what it
is
we've been waiting for September 28th
for a minute Earl Spencer jr. versus
Shawn Porter Shawn Porter versus Earl
spin jr. there's no B side here just two
champions ready to mix it up
that's sweet science and some tality
mixed up in it now that's exactly what I
expect to see but I'm gonna give you the
breakdown on how it is Oh y'all
understand when these grandmasters come
out mmm then it's a fight on when the
diamonds is poppin this one you got to
get dressed up for the show
Showtime versus a showstopper
okay the road leading up to this is
crazy
these guys training looking fantastic
slimming down getting ready both of them
making the wall to weight limit of 147
both of them look in this shape both of
them is ready to go this is crazy
but of course the person that answered
that bell to fight eros Prince jr. would
be Shawn Porter Shawn Porter has fought
Keith Thurman Danny Garcia
Berto granado's a Jim Verona Shawn
Porter resume it's a lot more impressive
than aerospace jr. it's not Earl's fault
though
a lot of these guys didn't want to get
in the ring but they have one guy in
common one guy in common tell Brooke let
me give you the breakdown on the Kell
Brook fights so you can understand where
I'm gonna go with this when Shawn Porter
for Kell Brook he had the IBF belt and
he was definitely the champion Kell
Brook is a bigger wall to weight and he
came over from London came over from
overseas to get that belt and these guys
fought and a high pitched battle Shawn
Porter fought his heart out
but what killed Brook was doing what's
nullifying him jab right hand step grab
turn right hand turn left hook grab step
jab grab step right hand turn body head
body Shawn Porter really couldn't get
his bearings in that fight he tried he
tried hard
but hey lost now you're talking about
Earl Spence and Kell Brook huh you see
Earl Spence is a big wall to weight as
well and being a big wall to weight
can't just push him around you just
can't grab him see Earl's Prince doesn't
like the whole doesn't like to grab he's
been taught the sweet science it's the
arrow Spence
he's an Olympian y'all know how I feel
about my lame pants my left hands baby
well-rounded know how to box inside and
out know how to bro can never sit he's
scared
then afford everybody around the world
so Earl Spence when he fought kill
Brooke sidestep body body see the thing
with Earl Spence when he hits you one
time he follows up directly if hitch
with a left hook definitely thrown right
hand if hitch with a left hook
definitely throwing another left hook
hitch would have right hand definitely
going to her body he works the body with
both hands did I mention the Earl
Spencer is a South Pole
Oh makes it more dangerous that
right-handed jab serious
Soquel Brooke couldn't do what kill
Brooke wanted to do I mean tell Brooke
gave it is all too big Walter waits now
keep in mind Shawn Porter is the only
person that fights people that nobody
wants to fight nobody want to fight Kell
Brook but Earl Spence was calling on
anybody who had a belt who smelled like
they had a name anybody they didn't want
Errol Spence into the show they didn't
want him
it's ro Spence goes over to London odds
stacked against them keep in mind
Kenny Porter's in the crowd ruining Earl
Spence on that Sean Porter's fault
this is deeper than rent so Prince goes
over to take step belt now he's back in
the states with the belt that Shawn
Porter used to have so now Earl Spence
is putting on a display you seen him
tearing up the wall to weight division
nobody wants to fight him
this is around the time that Shawn
Porter is fighting Keith Thurman Shawn
Porter and Keith Thurman fighters is a
good indication of what's gonna happen
same thing with the Kell Brook bigger
Walter weights push Shawn Porter around
he's not able to impose himself on them
bigger Walter weights don't allow Shawn
Porter to use his mauling style yeah oh
boy is a little bit reckless the sea and
his recklessness their lives the beauty
there lies the brutality he's a hundred
percent committed every shot every blow
he's inside he doesn't care who you are
he's ready to go toe to toe and you must
respect him to be honest with you you
would have said that he looks like
somebody like Dwight Muhammad quawi but
the white Muhammad cooiiy
had a smoother boxing tat style and
technique so I told you before Earl
Spencer reminds me of Terry Norris then
Terry Norris was a Oh a brutal fighter a
with a box chute that right hand see the
only thing with terrible Terry Norris he
didn't have a chin so let's talk about
the elephant in the room
let's talk about the Mikey Garcia versus
Earl Spencer jr. Mike he came up two
weight classes and everybody wanted
Spence to knock him out cold you see the
huge difference the huge difference is
hold on
the huge difference is Earl Spence kept
hearing how Mikey was gonna box rings
around him so what did he want to do he
wanted to show you his boxing IQ he
wanted to show you that he can box with
the best of them there Mikey isn't all
he's cracked up to be
and Mikey isn't the best at boxing Mikey
isn't smarter
I noticed points in that fight when Earl
Spence was carrying them he'll put his
foot on the gas
as soon as Mike he's getting ready to
buckle in he steps off the gas doesn't
do that in any other fight but that
fight he wanted to beat him for 12
rounds now you got Shawn Porter
he told Shawn Porter I'm gonna knock you
out cold
and the reason why he said that is
because he believes it anything that he
has said in this ring he has went out
and done let's give him the benefit of
the doubt the same way Shawn port ain't
never scared Earl Spencer lives up to
every last letter of his name so now
that's why he didn't knock out my key
wasn't because he couldn't you could
have killed my key he wanted to show a
different dimension now Shawn pota has
been dancing his last couple of fights
trying to extend his longevity and
what's been going on in this fight
build-up Shawn Porter is looking a
little uncharacteristic you're not
looking familiar baby you're all here
running your mouth talking I understand
you drumming up interest for the fight
this fight needed no interest drumming
all you did was further antagonize Earl
Spence see what you feel of belief or
what you fail to understand is you
antagonizing that man it's not taking
him out of this game pan you're making
them laser-focused so he can zoom in on
you so Shawn Porter has this mauling
style well he mauled Berto and he mauled
Pauley and he malls these guys and he's
reckless and he's swinging in his and
like I said it's organized chaos it's
masterful and it's unraveling because
you know he's gonna give you 110 percent
he's 100% committed to every shot and
there is the flaw you see I believe that
they're gonna come out going at each
other because Shawn Porter told you I'm
gonna make Earl Spitz feel me pause
you're gonna fail me when we in the ring
pause somebody should have tapped you on
the shoulder and said stop saying that
but back to the fight they're gonna get
in that ring and they're gonna go at it
is it gonna be Hagler horse we could
wish we could wish that is Hagler Hearns
well Shawn Porter is no Hagler the knurl
Spence's no Herms now we can hope that
they fight like that for one else Pence
has better legs than Hearns
and he's not that one punch killer shot
dealer and Shawn Porter damn showing no
Hagler Hagler was a switch hitting
absolute monster of a man you know you
fought him you had to pack it up or go
home or just understand tonight is your
night your night so now you got these
two combatants in the ring that's gonna
give you everything that they have great
weigh-in great lead up but this is where
the difference is this is where
in lies the rub we have a barnburner
tonight baby that bond is gonna be on
fire but as long as it lasts
Earl Spencer's gonna establish that
Japanese gonna work Shawn Porter to the
body he's gonna follow up with strong
left hands to the head followed by right
hooks Shawn Porter is gonna fight see
the thing with Sean Porter's and all
these clips that I'm showing you anytime
he's gotten hit he doesn't react well to
the hits he's usually there for double
up a return shot a follow combo I know
Spence is definitely done giving that
combo two piece and a biscuit I see Earl
Spence
by late stoppage probably two eight
seven seven seven something 2/9 just
because he don't really like old boy
never have and never will
this is combat talk with your king where
I bring you the good fight the fight you
want to see like following subscribe
catch you guys later
we give that Deontay Wilder Tyson Fury's
buddies or get that kovalev vs Canelo oh
man we got some good fights on deck
that's elevator
[Applause]
[Music]